Glastonbury Festival has no platform
door unstaged a band nobody has ever
heard of as its set list includes a song
called kill Tori scum
this is ridiculous it's a song title not
an order we seem to have gone backwards
since the Sex Pistols thank God Save the
Queen and her fascist regime or prodigy
released its global hit smack my up 30
years since Chinese protesters were
killed in Tiananmen Square we are
entering the age when the performance
arts in a liberal democracy are
suppressed lest they offend or shock
glass toe have them on children
themselves say they're only a 2-bit rave
punk band who pen politically-charged
slapstick anthems greek myths are
incredibly violent and transgressive
next we'll be banning nursery rhymes in
play school in fairy tales oh hold on we
have stop it everyone stop it now
creativity and freedom of speech not
conservative politicians in navy suits
and ties will be killed off if this
Stalin era repression continues yeah I
think you're just gobsmacked with your
with yours you clearly haven't seen the
video that goes with this song because I
can't believe you'd say the song with
okay so let me let me just let me just
tell you what's on that video it's so
bad we couldn't show it on television
not any part of it so they have they
have a woman MP who they they got
they're hiding the back of a car and
they go rata they send a bomb to a woman
mp's office a bloke walks behind them
woman MP with a massive baseball back to
cave her head in and then you see the
blood on the political not one not one
there's the kind of feeling there is a
better choice that also shows a sniper's
bullet taking Teresa Mays head off and
taking George bodyguards head off which
is no good so here we are so in the time
in at a time
this is this is people inciting people
to murder people for their political
beliefs and I will just say the name Joe
Cox Joe Cox was murdered by a fanatic
who had who acted on what he had read
and what he had seen this I think I
think this is this is it
this is a hate crime set to music
basically Carol I think it's a stretch
to argue that the killer of Joe Cox was
radicalized by by a music or creative
expression I think we know he is
radicalized by a far-right online
propaganda editor and at this point I'd
like to say I very much regret Joe Cox's
death and I don't want anyone to kill
anybody let alone Tory politicians of
whom three of which are my relations as
a result of any of their lyrics from
what killed Hren says with regard to
what they regard their creative
intention the piece would not exist at
all if the destructive and violent
policies of the Tory Party hadn't taken
such a long and devastated tolling on
the UK the band does not condone the
killing of Tories or children or anyone
for that matter regardless of political
beliefs they're a rubbish Punk bound
disingenuous let me just let me just say
first first of all I find it astonishing
that you've come to this debate without
having watched the video I find that
shocking because the video the video is
it's relevant the poor not gonna make
the video is appalling but not standing
as a standalone video not my full point
my full point is the following you just
read that statement and they're talking
about to all he gets I how I look with
my past as a Muslim if I suddenly made a
video talking about how many people
labor killed in Iraq because of the Iraq
war and started asking people to kill
the Labour Party in the name of Iraq you
bet you I'd be banned music this is my
point is why it actually upsets me
because you're blind to the racial
element and me and the religious element
here right there are jihadi songs on
line one actually is called kill the
infidel right and it's asking people to
kill the kill the Crafar is the word
they use and drill music has been bad to
rappers skåne don't a.m. were handed a
suspended
because they were banned from singing
certain lyrics and they violated the the
the order of the injunction and so they
were handed a two-year suspended
sentence these are young black kids in
urban estates and Muslims who aren't
allowed so you wouldn't be defending a
jihadi Sol online he's pushy at these
posh punk bands from Tunbridge Wells go
to Glastonbury where you have to pay
hundreds of pounds for a ticket when you
wear wellies people in I very rarely get
offended and I don't like it when people
get offended over nothing but I watched
this video I've never even heard of this
band by the way but so I watch this
videos for I came on set and I was
really quite outraged by this video and
I would challenge you to watch this
video and then repeat what you're saying
because I don't think you would I think
you'd change your view because the fact
the matter is people are influenced in
part by the music that they listen to
the bands that they follow whether it's
how they dress how they dance music
influences people and when you see a
video and you hear the lyrics kill
Torres come in the video it's disgusting
you're getting points for everybody
they're not video would not be on there
performing live at blasphemy we're
talking about the dirge produced by a -
Bob - brave band of Tiananmen Square
seriously do you not realise and cows
are written as indeed as magic touching
this there is actually dangerous anger
quite a dangerous anger out there
fortunately it didn't kick off with the
Jeremy Corbyn anti-trump demo because it
was raining apparently they didn't turn
out because it was raining it was a
weekday no well they can't feel it that
badly came and it just ended with a bit
of milk shaking which I'm not condoning
but we've seen how far it can go the Met
Police talked about they've took it on
my show there are preparations for if
there is a hard brexit know whatever you
want to call it there we cannot at this
time we cannot of this
close our eyes to the danger of
something like that I'm all for are not
being censored but something at this
level at this time we must you're
crediting it with far too much power
same band the same band have also
produced a song called save the world
which which incites
parents to kill their own children and
you know what middle-class spoiled kids
this is when they try to justify this
song they're not brave enough to
children because they think that nobody
is saying that we're vastly
overpopulated and we shouldn't have so
many choices
they are tone-deaf to how the times have
changed in the 1970s these sorts of
bands it was a different time right and
it's like back to this theme it's like
just after the Iraq war if I made a song
saying kill Labor Party members you
would instinctively know that it's
tone-deaf to the climate we're living in
now at the end of the day they this this
band still thinks that that kind of
stuff that used to be sung about in the
70s or rap with NWA F the police and a
nicety cop killer right that was of the
90s uncertain zeitgeist there is such a
thing as good and bad art now they
haven't been banned I'm just saying it's
incredibly bad art in poor taste
and it should never be they were they
wrote this whilst his climate was like
that but I think what year was the song
I think it was in time for the 2017
elections this isn't something rehab I'm
gonna give you listen to Commissioner
speaking last month Cressida day well we
believe that the current context is in
our policing time at least unprecedented
and some of the recent events including
the ghastly to annex an extraordinary
set of circumstances this is your
opportunity just look into the camera
so you've got this one if I believed
that anybody was so stupid and misguided
as to carry out the orders that's not
sorry Rachel
I am rubbish too big agitprop bad I
would can I just say well you know maybe
the words listen to the woods just
listen to some of what they say
[Music]
so what what she's saying is even if
it's your mom and dad kill him if
they're a Tory you think it's made to be
taken in today because you're saying
should it be taken literally some people
are taking this literally in 2017 not
151 peope MPs were victims of a crime in
2018 look it went up to 342 more than
doubled and that's crimes against MPs
racial people are taking a literally
just really I'm just really surprised at
you and important because we've been
discussing I think that we ought to see
what the chief executive of the Joe Cox
foundation has to say about this as well
it is never acceptable to incite
violence against anybody whether in
person online or on a public platform
the decision to withdraw this invitation
is very welcome we all have a
responsibility to call out threats and
intimidation of this kind it's fine to
have strongly held views but we must
work to ensure that we express our
disagreements without resorting to
violent language couldn't agree I know I
know what you all want me to say but I
just feel we're getting this out of
proportion
and it's a bit like when primal scream
released a track in 2001
Kabam the Pentagon and then actually a
man who'd been a vicious anti-semite who
was funded to the tune of many millions
by a anti-semitic regime did fly a plane
at the Pentagon I don't think it was
because he was a very sorry about what
happened to Joe and I am very sorry
about those attacks on MPs and I hope
nobody attacks MPs or anybody in public
life and so I'd like to make that very
clear